hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the trolley problem judith jarvis
thompson is considering the sorts of
cases originally brought forward for our
consideration
by flip a foot some of them involving
trolleys some of them involving
surgeons some involving hospitals and
poison gas and things like that and in
each of these there
is some sort of trade-off that has to
take place the death of five people
or the death of one and these
interesting problems puzzles conundrums
dilemmas ask
us not just to decide the case
but to explain why it is that some
things are
morally permissible perhaps even morally
required and why
other things would be morally prohibited
when they seem to produce
similar effects now philippa foot's
original solution to these issues framed
in terms
of the original trolley problem where
you're the trolley
driver and the surgeon who could take
you know a living person's five organs
without their consent
killing them in the process to
transplant them and save
five people these are originally dealt
with
by making this fundamental distinction
between
killing and letting die the idea is that
although letting people die is not a
good thing
sometimes avoiding killing another
person
can trump letting a larger number of
people
die and so there's a moral difference
between these two
now if it's a matter of killing people
and both
options involve killing people actively
doing something that kills people
then you can go by the numbers you can
say well we'll look at this in kind of
utilitarian way
we will minimize the amount of harm by
you know letting the trolley run over
one person
rather than then five people but
in the case of the surgeon who you know
could take the one person's
organs who is conscious who has said no
no i don't want to do this
what we have is a case of killing one
person
versus allowing five people through
inaction through not providing them with
organ transplants
to die and so foot says okay well that's
the difference between these
kinds of cases thompson says
okay let's let's dig into this we're
going to frame this in terms of
some theses and she talks about
you know she she frames this in terms of
some principles right she
says killing one is worse than letting
five
die um she's actually arguing
thompson that that's not true
although foot does think that it's true
so she says
i've been arguing that this is false and
that it cannot be appealed to to explain
why the surgeon may not
operate in the case i shall call
transplant
i think a lot of people would actually
buy that thesis though
that killing one person is worse than
letting five
die or two people die or perhaps 10
people
the other theses that she brings up are
killing five is worse than killing one i
think
pretty much everybody is going to buy
into that
and there are some questions though does
that tell us
what we want she says there's two ways
we can go here
we can say that two does tell us the
surgeon ought to operate
and that shows that that proposition
killing you know one is is better or
killing
five is worse than killing one
um that shows that that would be false
because we shouldn't have the surgeon
operating or we can say
this doesn't tell the surgeon that they
ought to operate and therefore
it's actually a true proposition in
which case
how is it how is it relevant right then
she goes on and she introduces another
one where she
which she calls to prime she says if a
person is faced with a choice between
doing something
here and now to five by the doing of
which he will kill them and doing
something else here
and now to one by the doing of which he
will kill only the one
then other things being equal he ought
to choose the second alternative rather
than first
notice the three qualifications there
right
here and now versus here and now not
here and now versus down the line or
here and now versus in the past the
doing of which will kill
right and there's also the other things
being equal all of these would have to
apply and she says that if that's the
case
then we we can take this to tell us that
the driver ought to and hence
permissibly may turn the trolley and
trolley driver
right at the same time it doesn't tell
us anything at all what the surgeon
ought to do in transplant
because he's not confronted by such a
choice if the surgeon operates
he does do something by the doing which
he will kill
one but if the surgeon doesn't operate
he does not do something he
refrains from doing something he merely
fails
to act and she says
i have no objection to this shift in
attention from to
to to prime but it's not really helping
us
and so what is the insight that she has
here
it's quite quite good and this shows how
bringing philosophy and its capacity for
making distinctions
to bear on these kinds of cases can
help us to better understand what we
ought to do
she says kill and let die these concepts
that that foot is saying we can use to
resolve this
are too blunt to be useful tools
for the solving of the problem isn't
that an interesting
way of putting it there's nothing wrong
with the distinction itself
but for these kinds of problems they
don't
go the distinction doesn't go
deep enough we need something more we
have to get
as they say a little bit more granular
so
maybe what we have to do then she
suggests is focus
on the ways in which the agents would be
carrying
these out carrying out killing
and letting die so
how can we approach that i mean one way
would be to
look at it uh from the point of view of
a utilitarian but that's just going to
focus on the consequences
she's saying it's not just the
consequences
and it's not just the nature of the
action itself that's going to give us
our solution
we need something more how what's
what are the ways which are going to
turn out in effect to be the means
for killing or letting die in these
kinds of cases
so she brings up the conscience second
formulation of the categorical
imperative if if you don't know emanuel
kant's
great works and his moral philosophy
here's sort of a thumbnail sketch he
came up with
some rules some very general rules that
apply
to tell us what is morally right what is
morally wrong what's demanded of us what
we should
avoid doing and how we can tell that an
action is in in fact you know
not just the right action to do but has
the right motive
and he came up with several formulations
of the categorical imperative the second
formulation says
act always so as to treat humanity in
yourself
and in others never as a mere means but
always
as an end which does include the
possibility of treating humanity in
other people or oneself as both an end
and a means
the point is we shouldn't just use
people
for some sort of purpose and it could be
something like
you know just using somebody in order to
get
physical pleasure from the engagement
with their body or to
get access to a party that you want to
go to
right or to have them spend money on you
and buy you consumer goods or
experiences that you want that's using
people right
and so in this case this would be much
much less trivial than those we're
using somebody in the sense of killing
them
this applies particularly to the case of
the surgeon right because he is
deliberately using the young man who
comes in for a medical
checkup and says says to this person
listen i want to
take your organs it's going to result in
you dying but it's going to save five
people i'm gonna use you
as a means to the end of
saving five other people and the guy
actually says
you know i sympathize but no no i will
not give consent to this so doing this
against their consent
is really a clear case of using them
now she goes on and she she expresses
some
puzzles i personally think that these
are not particularly great objections
even though i'm not a conscience myself
she says what exactly is it to treat a
person as a means only
or to use a person why exactly is it
wrong to do this these questions do not
have
obvious answers they don't have obvious
answers
when you frame them like that pecan does
provide us and many conscious do provide
us with some great answers
and then she raises a problem a case
that's kind of a quibble
and it's this it's with a trolley
problem instead of having the tracks
diverge
and then never converge again instead
imagine that the tracks are on a loop
so the only way to actually
stop the trolley is not just with the
means of
pulling the switch which by itself is
okay right but
the trolley's on a loop and the five
people are thin
the one person is fat the mass of the
fat person the mass of the five people
is sufficient to stop the trolley
from continuing on down the loop and
killing the other people in this case it
sounds like
when you save the five people by
flipping the switch
and having the trolley hit the one fat
person
you are using that one fat person as
a means to prevent the trolley from
going around and hitting
the other and you know this is
i think is is actually not a very good
objection but
she goes on and she says that
i should think there is no plausible
account of what is involved in or what
is necessary for the application of the
notions treating a person as a means
only or
using one to save five under which the
surgeon would be doing this whereas the
agent in this variant of bystander would
not be
if that's right then appeals to these
notions can't do the work
required of them there let's grant that
to her right
so then how else can we understand
what's going on in these ways in which
or the means
by which we're saving five
and killing one so
she says there's two facts that about
this
this trolley problem where you throw the
switch
turning the trolley onto the right-hand
track causing the one to be hit by the
trolley
saving the five there's two facts about
what he does that seem to me
to explain the moral difference between
what he does
and what the agent in transplant the
surgeon would be doing if he proceeded
now this is actually quite good
this is going to be a distinction that's
going to turn
up playing an important role a little
bit later on in it
saving five not just in any way
whatsoever
but saving five by making what
threatens them threaten only
one so she brought up cases for example
not just of runaway trolleys but
avalanches
you know poison gas these sorts of
things
if what you're doing is essentially
diverting the threat
that threatens the five so that it no
longer threatens them and only threatens
one
then that's an important issue now
couldn't you hit raise a problem that
the
fundamental the fundamental threat that
the people who are going to die of organ
failure have
is or indeed organ failure and that
if you were to take out the organs from
the young man well he would die of organ
failure as well
you probably could say that
but that's not a very good quibble
because what really what you're doing is
not just damaging the organs you're
taking
them out all together so that you can
transplant them into somebody else and
you're causing the death in that way so
i think that that possible objection
doesn't really uh touch this
this is going to be quite important and
is going to allow her
a little bit later to talk about an
important
we could call it qualifier or proviso
that that
makes an exception the other thing that
she says the other fact
and this is going to lead us into a much
longer discussion
is that the person making the decision
engaging in the action
does not use means that infringe
the one person's rights
now that's going to require a lot more
unpacking
and discussion because on its face it
would seem like well
you are infringing on their rights
because you're killing them they have a
right to life
but maybe there's a way of understanding
the concept of rights that allows us to
squeeze these things in these kinds of
actions so these two
facts would be sort of a replacement for
you know a conscient approach there
would also be a replacement for a
utilitarian approach or other approaches
and this is the way that
thompson thinks we really need to go in
order to
figure out why the bystander at the
switch
can or perhaps even should flip the
switch whereas the surgeon
in transplant ought not to do that
you